bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo fantasmagorico video di
rust che è un gioco che stanno
tantissimo ultimamente siete soli a
cavalcare per verdi praterie con il sole
sulla faccia non preoccupatevi troppo
perché sarete nei praticamente si sono
create un miliardo di community
io parteciperò un po a tutti e quattro
per vedere cosa succede oggi siamo con
march che noia step per capire il modo
migliore per giocare e creare delle
alleanze ma non sappiamo quando alla
fine di gaby e cotica in più più più ma
se sono io sono io e non pensavo che tu
eri più forte del server quindi non
sapevo chi seguire anche il nostro
giocare bravo è stata presa e corso timo
sicuro era preso io corso ma non c'era
un motivo vi però se posso dire io per
terra prima e ragazzi diventano tutti
ammassati ho raccolto nelle cose che non
sono utili per niente però guarda ok ma
il come ho sentito dire che mai social
ed un pedaggio per la sua base se lo
troviamo
questo è il pedaggio che gli potremo
offrire ad angela esatto in una rivale
forte
ok però non possiamo andare nudi come
minimo dobbiamo vestirci quindi va beh
sì ma tu sei questi fari vestiti e credo
che dobbiamo far fuori un orso un
animale però e difficili se va bene
il problema allora prima di tutto
dobbiamo al presidente forza nato qua ci
sono delle 0 inizia a spaccare alberi
che credo di maicon e roccia per
spaccarla tutta una roccia
vai vai vai a mangiare poi mi sono tutti
i denti era veramente una torta di
quelle che l'isola e che comunque si si
è spaccata da dalla torta cioè non è
così ne esiste allora porco cane
venivamo la da parte è meglio trova
troverò una roccia da qualche parte
spero in un farmaco quella che sta
seguendo i rumori di te che sradichi
robe perché se no non ti trovo allora
anche se non per provare la data dal
gioco ecco ecco ecco che il bellissimo
abbiamo perso ormai col numero uscì una
caverna fair no davvero
quanto c'è una caverna e c'è una vince
un coso di me di minerali l'ho visto
l'ho visto perfetto aveva abbiamo
trovato una zona assurda che roba
minerali ma noi abbiamo tutto qua noi
abbiamo più iniziamo benissimo oddio
cena roba aspetta che lo vedo più niente
un certo punto c'è la roba valutare
aspettami alla roccia la puoi craftare
che lo precede un altro barcone di
metallo mamma mia
melo passi nei due erano piccoli e
allora tieni quasi sicura su
assolutamente un piccolo appartamento
una roba bruttissima senti a casa
contento degli animali ho detto mi sono
sentito niente e per ora spetta
io ci ho paura c'è un'altra rojas a
valutare vi dico perfetto di lei
se vuoi prenderlo devi lasciare stesse
perfetto rocchi occhio qua una buca mai
domande ci sono delle stiracchiata ed io
ci possono provare aiuto no ti prego
aspetta io prego loro giustamente perso
tutto quello che avevo che napoli ora
puoi andare nudo riprovaci era
difficilissimo perfetto non ci si può
non si può che riuscivo calare
io non ci provo io ho paura non ci
provano invito aspetta si può fare un
tratto passaggio di giugno è un
passaggio
sì sì per arrivare in passato forse
forse è scaduta natale vediamo
ho trovato una torcia vediamo se la
vicina mi sto riprendendo nato e al
cielo
mammamia meno male ma mi ha sacrificato
un pò fà mi sono fatto un male cane
ho trovato 88 delle robe qualche di b ho
trovato lo green fuel da robben che ha
mai fatto capire quello che ci è
riuscito
mi sono preso malissimo va bene allora
la mia carrozza dell'europa e che ti
posso dare attenzione guarda che roba
nostra governo indiano una donna
adesso dico adesso guarda mi ti prego
guardami vedi che succede
guardami no non si può godersi è un tra
modello è un cappello da minatore
promette una sotto alimentario vede che
ci sono degli slot ce l'hai
ma c'e la torcia come si fa io non lo so
ma dov'è la pro belle e togli la torcia
toglie che eccola
eccola bellissimo utile no vabbè ragazzi
ciao né allora ma si può picconare sta
roba serve si no prendiamo tutti i
materiali perché bellissimo minatori
veri maniaci alla caverna ma qui
progetti giorno ci troveranno male è
impossibile veramente sapremo miliardo
di pietre o la partenza secondo me noi
non so come stava per segnare
niente non voglio farla migliore
dovremo solo rinforzarci a livello di
vendite e poi un arma vera come si può
fare veramente quel cialtrone
vediamo un niente di che era un aspetto
sesta roma stona c'è una accetta di
pietra quindi niente per niente io non
so manco mori ma enorme suo posto c'è
veramente quote non ci perdiamo no qua
non si può andare fatevi quella dinamica
borsa non è che se picconi no
non credo forse chiuso però ottenuto la
di là c'è un'altra via ok ma anche
quadri no non è chiuso e chissà che l'ha
definita fin fine dei giochi
becca bene line e stato divertente
finora cosa tipo di nuovo gli strani
abbiamo ci farà meglio o meglio che ce
ne andiamo meglio che ci andiamo di qui
abbiamo preso abbastanza gori d'asta
caverna tra l'altro oltretutto non ti ho
detto ho preso anche di minerali di
metallo fatto benissimo benissimo ci
facciamo l'upgrade della base perfetto
ora il problema è fare quel punto quindi
farlo privato oppure da misura fu mai
più semplice comunque trovo type jolo no
dai sei uscito fuori si si si stempera
virus
allora non lo so ci provo ce l'ha fatta
solo fortissimo
mamma mia è stata da vivente è stato
facile entrarci ma uscire ad uscire un
casino però ce l'ho fatta ci sei hai
provato arriva mamma mia mamma mia
casino per riuscire a trovare il vero
comunque pieno zeppo di ma tu col
piccone cioè proprio non è calma perché
poi tratto credo che ti di api roba
perché io veramente il social non sono
un caso movimentare un piano zero amiche
minatore provetto si faceva questo che
facciamo un'altra tra l'altro che ogni e
non ce l'avrebbe anche la rem i
materiali sono paura che la gente si
trovi
la roba seria anche se l'italia adesso
ci facciamo una base così tanto per
sopravvivere cioè ma che ci spostiamo
perché la fine è quella di legno easy
certo certo
questo comunque metallo quindi tanta
roba utile ma domani è vivissima la
scelta delle robe che questa qua altezze
tu prendi la ics se colpisci la icsi la
piroga oddio è cascato addosso forti che
ti dà un sacco di lane già mille basta
veramente pieno di roba
anzi bisogna pero me non sono niente
quindi più facilmente costante ricorso
del viaggio il pass ma andiamo da
maestro jean con le torte facciamo
lavorare poi troviamo qualcosa che cosa
ciò io che ho notato nell'orto un
iniziale che qualcuno ha buttato per
terra la trappola per orsi che non è
male se andiamo di nichi vediamo i loro
spostamenti poi metti la trappola ma
bravo cosa facciamo qui allora dovremmo
almeno chiudere quale pure mettere una
cesta così almeno possiamo queste queste
quattro mura facciamo un pezzo però ci
vuole il frame a possiamo tra l'altro a
gridarlo sullo stomaco il marcello
guardato fare certo lo guarda e
facendosi figlio l'upgrade e allora in
maniera per qualcosa così non ce l'hai
arrivano perfetto si sia perfetto si
rifanno le fondamenta per forze si
possono però ora giocatori non c'è pure
questo è vero tanto costa ma io sono
ricco col ricco e mamma mia amatissima
ne vanno
ma io ora chiedo io non ho usato niente
di tutto quello che auto lo assicuro
sono pieno mamma mia
allora chiudi gli ultimi muri con la
legna e sinistra se vogliamo hurley ha
meno me li fa ma forse perché non
abbiamo senza legno perché devi averne
almeno 50 io ne ho 1700 allora ottimo
abbiamo fatto tutto e obiettivo prossimo
trovare un salto di roccia a prescindere
da quello è perché ci serve se armati a
dire andiamo cerca andiamo un po in giro
la cerchiamo con ancora più clot
possiamo farci largo che quello è utile
e molto utile esamine che gli devo dare
la mela al cavallo ma probabilmente dai
senza così a va bene va bene va bene
questo ruolo ce n'è un altro renderlo
perfetto se c'è un altro pentito storico
dove l'ho visto aspetta o con tipo siano
danni già parlava proposto è cavolo si
eccolo là ce lo vedo lo vedo vedo
ok dove stavamo andando vicino alla
macchina eccolo lì in mezzo alla
prateria lo vedo meno che non sia un
bite di qualcuno io ho paura piccola
resti cosi che secondo me esplodono però
fammi vedere il simbolo del gas sono
rossi
ci provo dai valdostani lontano ti prego
esplodo ancora più non ho mai mai mai
mai partita è la madonna
ok non sta esplodendo non precludendo
cosa avevo dell'olio della benzina
penso ci serve io farei le armi comunque
perché leggo che hanno le armi l'hanno
scritto una pistola e incredibile mai ce
l'abbiamo già abbiamo noi sparo un colpo
in lodi breve lo tieni tu
c'è un cartello di stop questo trend non
si sa mai ora vai un po di esplorazione
cerchiamo di trovare il nostro primo
team da rapinare da rapinare
ecco io avevo una pistola siamo rapidi
la romagnola ma io il piccolo ma il
cavallo e la lancia liberati la lancia
neanche prove mi sono i tiratori di
avere fai una faccio una il prendo anche
qualche legna al volo nel caldo di
lavoro si anch'io
andiamo secondo me finisce malissimo
proprio sicuramente in un bagno di
sangue si fa più pena loro dai sì sì per
loro certo certo
e qui dentro non c'è niente scusa ecco
quasi che c'è la roba acqua sa bene in
quanto abbiamo provato qui morendo
tantissimi hanno fatto mi sembrano
supermercato nel supermercato poi si
volesse lunga purtroppo devo provare a
trovare da mangiare perché sto morendo
vediamo se c'è qualcosa una boxe eccolo
eccolo qua cioccolato mangia dei fagioli
e stata romanista giochi effetto bud
spencer
ok procedere mai di roma oddio trovato
non ho trovato ho trovato la guarda noi
trovato lato tanti radiazioni pazzesco
possiamo andare aiutare
secondo il capitano 9 va adesso possiamo
prenderlo va aprendo roba per otranto
una green una green key card
adesso mi saluti timore comunque io non
hanno la vorrei esporre perché come la
vedono mi ammazzano fortissima però dice
voglio adesso posso lottare per entrambi
in posti esse infatti in quel punto
dov'eravamo perimetro verranno di
brindisi ma anche qua adesso è qui di
fianco ce n'è uno stato o sento cavalli
sei tu che mondo ma pensavo degli
esterni
prendi tipo qua non ci puoi andare
ok allora ci ora ci può andare a ora che
ci posso andare si meno male possibile
metterlo scrat normale controllo che per
fare perché va dentro [ __ ] 9 più
ovviamente utili parola spetta qui c'è
una porta ma scoprirà cavolo peccato per
ora ok tu solo una cesta ok un bar
penale va bene dai adesso muoviamoci un
po vediamo se troviamo una base per un
rapido uno che per questa roba che ho
trovato andrei tranquillissima
mentalmente cioè che una volta era di
perderlo se non se se vuoi guardarmi
fatto io un attimo ho trovato una base
come ad una fase nascondini cespugli e
11 astenuti non dobbiamo dare quei
cavalli e il cavallo non siamo qui
lasciamolo cui per adesso perché se ci
avviciniamo con il cavallo civile ma lo
troviamo qui l'ho trovata qua la voce
gente ci siete non è male e l'hanno
fatta per quella nostra se non si
aspetta allora allora facciamo una cosa
è un piano piano pian piano allora tu
gli vai con la torta gliela offre di ci
sono da solo cioè proprio perché sono un
hub
appena lui si distrae oliva dove la
pistola lo minaccio vedi un po la
situazione va bene l'ho visto fare anche
ingenui che sta roba
vai vai vai vai vai vai trattamento
completo che va dai ragazzi questo era
il primo è bisogno di rust con tutta la
crew e gambi secondo me ce la caviamo
adesso abbiamo stanziato un po sulla
faccenda però sono convintissimo che
spaccheremo tutte le che vi siamo
veramente un gran tv però mi avete
sempre 100 ragazzi così mi piace anche
alle società commentato letizia re.se.t
siede anche le cose belle ragazze
[Musica]